الازبه الاوكرانيه والمفاوضات لحلها ملف
ما زال مفتوحا مع رفض الطرفين الجلوس الى
طاوله المفاوضات حاليا الرئيس الاوكراني
فالدو ميرسيلنسكي قال في الثلاثين من
سبتمبر الماضي انه مستعد للحوار مع روسيا
لكن مع رئيس اخر غير فلاديمير بوتن وفي
اليوم التالي اصدر مرسوما رئاسيا باستحاله
اجراء محادثات مع بوتن الرد الروسي حينها
كان ان موسكو اما ستنتظر ان يغير زينسكي
موقفه او ان يغير الرئيس الاوكراني المقبل
لصالح شعبه
الطرفان متباعدان في هذا الصدد وافاق
تسويه تبدو بعيده الا ان المؤشرات تدل على
وجود رغبات دوليه في ان يعود الطرفان
للتفاوض بلوره رؤيه للحل
واشنطن بدورها قالت على لسان المتحدث باسم
مجلس الامن القومي جون كوربي ان الامر
متروك للرئيس جيلنسكي ليقرر ما اذا كان
مستعدا ام لا ومتى سيكون مستعدا للتفاوض
وما هو الشكل الذي سيتخذه هذا التفاوض
الموقف الامريكي يظهر دعما للتفاوض الا ان
الرئيس الروسي قال ان واشنطن تدير
دبلوماسيه كياف كما يدير تنتجون المعارك
من الجانب الاوكراني على حد قوله بوتن
من ناحيه تظهر الولايات المتحده دعما
للمصاري الدبلوماسيه بينما تدفع بمساعدات
لاوكرانيا لتحقيق غايات لدى الاداره
الامريكيه مجله نيوز ويك تناولت هذا
الموضوع تحديدا وقالت ان المساعدات
الامريكيه لاوكرانيا استثمار كبير
للولايات المتحده التي تنفق مبالغ قليلا
نسبيا للوصول الى مكاسبه اكبر خاصه اذا
هزمت روسيا منذ بدايه الحرب
13 مليارا و600 مليون دولار كمساعدات
للاوكرانيين وفي مايو وافق مجلس الشيوخ
على ما يقرب من اربعين مليار دولار كدعم
الاضافي يشمل النواحي العسكريه
والاقتصاديه والانسانيه وفي منتصف الشهر
الجاري طلب البيت الابيض من الكونجرس
الموافقه على 38 مليار دولار اخرى من
المساعدات والانسانيه لاوكرانيا قالت ان
المساعده تمثل خمسه ونصف المئه من اجمالي
الانفاق الدفاعي الامريكي وتوفر فرصه
للولايات المتحده لتقويض القدره الدفاعيه
التقليديه لروسيا دون ارسال جندي واحد الى
ارض المعركه لمواجهه التهديد الروسي كما
نقلت نيوزويك عن محللين قولهم ان حجم
الاموال التي تنفقها الولايات المتحده على
اوكرانيا لا شيء لا شيء مقارنه بما تحصل
عليه واشنطن في المقابل سواء على ارض
المعركه بخساره روسيا او بحدوث تغييرات في
الداخل الروسيه
[موسيقى]
في مصر
قال على شاشه التلفزيون الرسمي ان
المفاوضات الروسيه مع اوكرانيا حيله
لتاخير الحرب حتى تستعيد روسيا قوتها
للهجوم ومواصله القتال ياتي حديث السياسي
الروسي بينما قالت المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه
الروسيه ماريا زخرفه ان روسيا منفتحه على
محادثات السلام ومستعد للتفاوض
فلبين قال ان مواطنيه سعداء بالضربات
الروسيه على اوكرانيا الا ان الضربات لن
تهزمك يا اف لكنها قد تدفعها لطاوله
المفاوضات كما اعتبر ان روسيا تريد
التفاوض كغاء لاعاده جمع قواتها وانهاء
القتال في وقت لاحق على الرغم من اي
اتفاقات سلام محتمله اعتبر السياسي الروسي
ان اتفاقات منسك بدات نتيجه انتصارات
عسكريه حاسمه لروسيا وانه اذا كان الجانب
الروسي يريد المفاوضات حقا فانه لن يحتاج
ايضا الى تعزيز مصر العسكري وانهاء الحرب
على ساحه المعركه وليس بالتفاوض لن يحتاج
الا لتعذيذه وضعه العسكري
[موسيقى]